Mother was very young,
she was mentally ill and it was a period
of time when 30 years ago when people
didn't know the difference between she
it paranoid schizophrenia,
manic depression,
they didn't know how to treat it,
so she was kind of self medicating with
alcohol.
This bond that's supposed to happen
because it keeps going back to
relationships and bonding.
She wasn't really able to show up as a
mother and as I understand it,
your neurochemistry doesn't develop a
certain way as an infant and you need
kind of jolts,
so you're kind of being prepared to be a
love addict in that way,
and she was also,
for me,
the original love junkie.
If you've looked at the book,
there's that line.
My mother cried over all the men in her
life and so clearly there was a
depressive thing which has an effect on
kids.
Again,
laying the groundwork.
She wasn't really available,
so I'd be reading fairytales,
which no doubt fed into romantic ideas
of love,
sacrifice,
yearning because you're yearning to have
the original attachment.
Then layer on top of that,
the father,
again,
they were both young.
It's not about blaming them and in fact,
that's been a big part of breaking out
of this cycle is it's not anyone's
responsibility except your own.
You're an adult at this point.
Let's go.
It's enough.
You're not going to get the parental
love.
That would've been ideal.
We already had a mentally ill mother,
which has its own,
a drama in the house.
And there was always chaos and drama.
And uh,
her choices kept getting worse.
And men,
her next choice for her husband was
someone who was very violent,
who had named himself to get out of
going to Vietnam.
He was a alcoholic,
a very abusive controlling.
So he ran out.
And I'm glad my mother had enough
presence of mind to take me.
And we were off to New York and left
that.
And she was seven months pregnant at the
times.
Very.
Yeah.
So interestingly,
that,
that aspect of the Dickensian,
just these overblown incidents,
which I didn't really think of that way
when I was growing up because you can't,
that's the confusing thing too.
You get so into your survivor mode and
gallows humor.
Um,
but the truth is now when I look back
and this memoir was a hugely informative
for this,
I realized that that was one of the
spots like there what ad words worth
call it spots in time,
that kind of flashpoints where I
experienced a fusion of fear and
pleasure.
And that I think that violent experience
in the abuse there really had something
to do with informing some of my choices
with ex cons and various other unsavory
but exciting seeming smart,
charming,
but dangerous men.
Later on.